[Musique]
envoyer des photos de soie nude à
quelqu'un qui est consentant ça ne pose
pas de difficulté encore une fois on est
dans une conversation intime
il ya une demande de photos ou pas de
demandes de photos on envoie une photo
ça pose pas de problème aujourd'hui
c'est devenu une nouvelle façon de faire
l'amour de capter des photos et des
vidéos et de les envoyer
c'est excitant et donc c'est une
nouvelle modalité de la vie érotique
s'il n'y a pas eu de demande si on est
dans un autre moment je sais pas vous
êtes au bureau et puis il ya un gars qui
pense à vous qui dit je pense à toi il
envoie une photo de son sexe
c'est pas théorique je pense que ça
arrive comment ça se passe est-ce que
c'est autorisé non c'est pas autorisé
si c'est un envoi unique on peut parler
d' outrage sexistes qui est un délit si
vous en voyez plusieurs fois des
messages malveillants par la voie
électronique
vous risquez un an de prison 15 mille
euros damende si vous en voyez tous les
jours des messages à caractère sexuel et
des photos qui ne sont pas demandées
vous pouvez être condamné pour
harcèlement sexuel
trois ans de prison et 45000 euros
d'amendé il peut y avoir une atteinte à
l'intégrité de la personne qui reçoit
des images à caractère sexuel et donc on
va chercher à protéger sa moralité sa
santé en regardant si elle était bien
consentante si elle était bien en âge de
recevoir c'est ces images et quelle
était l'intention de l'auteur qui les a
envoyés
ça peut être aussi de l'exhibition
sexuelle si vous postez de vous même
avec votre pleine et entière
consentement sur facebook n'importe qui
une vidéo de vous c'est de l'exhibition
sexuelle c'est interdit article 222 tiré
32 du code pénal
[Musique]
si vous divulguer une photo à caractère
sexuel de quelqu'un qui était d'accord
pour qu'elle soit prise et qui vous l'a
envoyée mais que vaut la divulguer sans
son consentement vous risquez deux ans
de prison et 60000 euros damende si vous
partagez cette même photo après l'avoir
reçu même de façon licite mais que la
vidéo est illicite
vous êtes complice de ce délai le droit
à la vie privée fait que bien entendu si
vous recevez dans le cadre de l'intimité
une photo ou si vous vous adressez une
normalement il faut la détruire il peut
y avoir une aggravation si vous prenez
connaissance des photos ou des vidéos
par fraude
attention à ceux en plus qui diffuse
partagent les vidéos illicite à contenu
sexuel pour faire du buzz
ils sont complices du délit dans la
mesure où si et censé disparaître
instantanément si vous faites une copie
d'écran par définition vous ne respectez
pas le contrat de base donc là il ya
véritablement une infraction qui est
plus grave que si vous la recevez par
texto ou la personne sait que ça peut
être automatiquement enregistrées sur
téléphone sur votre ordinateur sur votre
tablette
[Musique]
il ya la réglementation sur la
protection des données personnelles qui
régit le droit au retrait qui fait qu'on
a le droit de s'adresser au service de
publication en ligne de photos pour les
contraindre à retirer dès lors que
l'utilisation des données qui ont été
faites n'a pas d'utilité pour le service
en cause on va dire en ce qui concerne
les cloud qui a un consentement
implicite mais c'est très très bien fait
un par les exploitants de logiciels et
de matériels pour que tout ça nous
échappe totalement
en réalité le consentement il est jamais
vraiment donné et donc il ya un droit au
retrait qui existait déjà avant
l'existence des réseaux sociaux et le
fait que l'on se surexpose soi même